[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravi de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de savouregard à
la une ce soir l'assassinat de Samuel
Paty 2 ans après où en est-on que faire
face à un phénomène qui semble prendre
de l'ampleur ses élèves qui viennent en
cours vêtus d'une abeille à ou d'un
camis la laïcité est-elle menacée dans
nos écoles les enseignants se sont-ils
suffisamment soutenus l'école et son
rôle on en parlera aussi dans la seconde
partie de l'émission avec notre grand
témoin la journaliste Sophie Coignard
qui publie la tyrannie de la médiocrité
un plaidoyer pour la méritocratie enfin
du côté de nos affranchis ce soir nous
serons avec Mariette d'Harry grand qui a
choisi pour mot de la semaine le mot
grève Brandon warrett nous offrir un
coup d’œil dans le rétro après les
rappels alors qui ont ponctué les vive
échanges de cette semaine à l'Assemblée
en fin elles amont d'un Gava nous
expliquera comment le gouvernement mais
aussi les députés se préparent à
l'utilisation très probable du 49-3 sur
le budget voilà pour le sommaire c'est
parti pour ça vous regarde
[Musique]
et pour débattre de cette actualité
j'accueille sur ce plateau Nadia est
bonsoir vous êtes député renaissance des
Yvelines élus de la circonscription de
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine où se trouvait
le collège de Samuel Paty et ancienne
ministre délégué chargé de la ville
Maxime Lainé bonsoir vous êtes député la
France insoumise de Seine-et-Marne et
avant d'être élu député vous avez été
enseignant professeur des écoles jusqu'à
très récemment je crois Alain sexy
bonsoir vous vous êtes ancienne
inspecteur général de l'Académie de
l'éducation nationale on peut dire et
aujourd'hui secrétaire général du
Conseil des Sages de la laïcité enfin
Fatiha agagujalat nous rejoindra dans
quelques instants principal adjointe
dans un collège et essayer voilà pour
les présentations lui on ne le présente
plus Stéphane blackovski
[Musique]
bonsoir Stéphane invité qui me
connaissait pas alors qu'on me présente
je vous présente un autre invité notre
chroniqueur Stéphane blackkowski alors
Stéphane si j'ai bien compris si j'ai
bien compris Clément le dimanche 16
octobre c'est donc pas seulement la
grande marche contre la vie chère on
était au courant c'est aussi on vient de
s'en rappeler la manière la plus
présente dans l'actu la date
anniversaire de l'assassinat de Samuel
Paty donc il y a pas forcément de
concurrence d'ailleurs entre ces deux
événements parce que la gauche organise
une grande marche contre la vie chère
l'après-midi mais le matin il y a aussi
une petite manif on écoute bien
évidemment qu'il faut honorer la mémoire
de de Samuel Paty et en ce qui nous
concerne les différentes forces de la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale on a prévu dimanche matin de
faire un rassemblement sur la place
Samuel Patier pour lui rendre hommage
alors ce qu'on peut dire c'est que à
l'Assemblée nationale l'hommage a été
unanime c'était assez beau le ministre
est venu il a prononcé le nom de Samuel
Paty et vous allez regarder avec moi la
réaction de l'ensemble des députés donc
on applaudit au départ vraiment ici que
et c'est l'ensemble de l'hémicycle qui
va se lever alors la gauche s'est levée
en premier vous allez le constater la
droite voyant la gauche debout nous
aussi on va se lever là le gouvernement
est assis en bas oh il se lève aussi
dans la dernière finalement c'est Gaëlle
bonne qui est vrai qu'il va ah ouais va
se rendre compte qu'il faut le soleil
aussi voilà les lampes c'est fait
spontanément c'est une très belle image
d'unité mais il y a quand même eu des
petites tensions autour des hommages
organisés autour de cette date par
exemple vous avez peut-être entendu
parler que Zemmour veut organiser un
rassemblement demain à Paris il avait
prévu de faire ça à 14h près de la
Sorbonne et donc il s'indigne parce
qu'en fait le ministre sera lui-même
présent dans le quartier donc il a dû
changer d'heure ça réunion à 10h30 je
pense qu'il écrit à la censure donc vous
voyez ce que ça veut dire que c'est le
retour d'Éric Zemmour mais oui
apparemment vous voyez donc c'est
l'anniversaire de la mort de Samuel Paty
fait ressortir Zemmour de là où il était
pourtant l'an dernier la famille de
Samuel Paty avait été assez sévère avec
lui en disant que il y avait une
indécence totale
va utiliser Samuel Paty comme un
argument électoral mais un jour c'est on
respecte de gloire de la famille mais ce
qu'a dit sans voter pour Zemmour vous
voulez reconnaître que l'assassinat de
Samuel Paty c'est comme un argument pour
ceux qui s'inquiètent de la montée de
l'islamisme dans ce pays des progrès que
fait l'islamisme et notamment dans les
écoles surtout que on voit bien qu'il y
a une sorte d'offensive islamiste en ce
moment dans les écoles alors le terme
offensive que vous employez qu'est-ce
qui vous fait employer ce terme
j'ai l'air affreusement de droite en
disant ça j'ai dit offensive islamiste
je voudrais peut-être être plus prudent
après tourner son service public non
mais regardez dans les journaux on l'a
vu tout le monde l'a constaté c'était
frappant en Alsace ou un professeur a
été menacé par quelqu'un de la famille
parce qu'il avait parlé des caricatures
des courriers avec des menaces
antisémites en Essonne moi je veux bien
croire que ce soit des événements isolés
le problème c'est que il y a des
fonctionnaires en France qui sont
chargés de la lutte contre la
radicalisation et ils font le même
constat il y a une note au gouvernement
qui a été envoyée pour dire que il y
avait en ce moment une offensive
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux pour
activer cette envie de porter des
vêtements qui affichent l'identité
musulmane enfin sur le plan religieux
bon en même temps c'est pas une
découverte voyez ça c'est au mois de
juin donc Marianne avait déjà écrit un
article de moi avant la note
présidentielle donc c'est quelque chose
malgré tout qui était assez sensible et
comment réagit le ministre de
l'Éducation alors c'est universitaire
donc il a donné une grande interview au
Monde où le titre qui était mis en une
dans le journal c'était la République
est plus forte que Tik Tok donc il
faisait un peu référence assez réseaux
sociaux à mon avis il devrait quand même
pas se méfier je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez sur le mouvement des gilets
jaunes le rôle qui a pu jouer à Facebook
donc quand on dit que les réseaux
sociaux peuvent jouer un rôle important
pour fédérer un mouvement oui ça il faut
se méfier certainement de Tik Tok cela
dit on veut pas dire que Miss France à
la légère regardez il était sur France 2
récemment il notait une augmentation de
des signalements de comportement qui
sont contraires à la laïcité
il est vrai que depuis un an le nombre
de signalements relatifs à des tenues
disons islamiques augmentent on sent une
sorte de prudence je sais pas combien
parce que il parle lui-même de tenue
islamique mais en revanche quand il
s'agit de désigner les salafistes et les
Frères musulmans qui sont à l'origine de
cette propagande là il a besoin du
sous-titrage de Thomas Soto en écoute
cela peut être en effet sous tendu par
des agitateurs professionnels
stratégie d'entrisme salafo frériste et
les frères ni de bien à l'école ni de
bien à la République nous ne sommes pas
naïf là dessus je vous ralentis pas sur
le débat juste 5 secondes si vous me
laissez 5 secondes pour diffuser un
petit sonore quelqu'un qui va parler
c'était au Mureaux en octobre 2020 il y
a 2 ans on écoute
ce à quoi nous devons nous attaquer
c'est le séparatisme islamiste c'est 5
secondes c'est à 2 ans voilà c'était
juste avant d'assassinat de Samuel Paty
merci beaucoup Stéphane
on va l'évoquer cette loi contre les
séparatistes qui vient de fêter LC1 an
Nadia est vous avez le sentiment que
cette loi a produit ses effets
aujourd'hui
oui alors juste avant de rentrer dans le
détail de la loi je veux juste
intervenir très rapidement ma qualité
des luttes Conflans-Sainte-Honorine je
pense que le plus bel hommage le plus
beau des hommages que nous pouvons
rendre à Samuel Patty c'est de ne pas
utiliser sa mémoire à des fins
politiques et cette référence à tout ce
qui se rassemblement d'Éric Zemmour qui
a été évoqué par Stéphane dacoche je
fais référence à tous ceux qui utilisent
sa mémoire à des fins politiques et donc
oui en premier lieu Éric Zemmour mais à
d'autres aussi qui seraient tentés par
utiliser ce crime abject cet attentat
qui qui reste encore vraiment
très très présent dans la vie des
conflansais et de tous les voisins
effectivement en effet de cette de cette
ville donc vraiment j'insiste sur ce
fait là je crois que le plus beau des
hommages c'est d'honorer sa mémoire pour
ne pas oublier ce souvenir mais surtout
agir mais il y a quand même ces deux
agir c'est ce que nous faisons ces deux
faits divers en quelques jours là
Stéphane les a évoqué on va te faire une
Samuel Paty c'est la menace anonyme qui
a été reçue
par un enseignant d'Évry Courcouronnes
ciblé en raison de sa confession juive
il y a cette autre enseignant qui a été
menacé par l'oncle d'une élève en Alsace
pour avoir évoqué les caricatures de
Mahomet en cours vous avez vraiment le
sentiment aujourd'hui que
on a progressé que aujourd'hui la
laïcité est confortée deux ans après
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty non moi ce
que je note c'est qu'il y a encore des
faits inacceptables aujourd'hui ou la
laïcité mise à mal mais surtout des
menaces vis-à-vis du corps enseignant et
ça c'est inacceptable il ne faut pas
transiger là-dessus sur la sécurité de
notre personnel de tout le milieu
éducatif donc il faut être intraitable
vis-à-vis de ces actes là et puis
ensuite effectivement aujourd'hui notre
modèle est mise à mal mais il est mis à
mal par finalement une force aujourd'hui
obscur ou pas mais en tout cas une force
aujourd'hui qui met un mal notre modèle
qui s'attaque à notre République et
assez valeurs et sur lequel il faut agir
et la loi qui est forte les principes
républicains qui a été voté à
l'Assemblée nationale à corriger
certains angles morts de notre arsenal
législatif mais elle ne saurait
aujourd'hui lutter sur finalement les
mentalités sur aussi parfois ces jeunes
qui sont en totale recherche de leur
identité et qui opère se replient
séparatiste et qui sont récupérés par
ces réseaux que nous devons évidemment
aujourd'hui neutraliser sur lequel nous
devons absolument rien céder Laurent
sexy que disent ces deux ces deux faits
divers là en quelques jours deux ans
après l'assassinat de Samuel Paty
comment est-ce qu'il faut les ils disent
que le mal est profond
et qu'en effet il faut savoir réagir
pour comprendre ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui on est obligé de revenir
plus de 30 ans auparavant lorsque éclate
la toute première affaire de voile la
toute première affaire médiatisée de
voir en collège c'est à Creil
et alors médiatisé je dis parce que
quatre ans auparavant il y en avait une
dans un lycée dans un collège de Créteil
personne jamais n'en a entendu parler
la principale du collège l'équipe
enseignante confrontée à la présence de
deux jeunes filles deux collégiennes qui
portaient un voile de savais même pas
nommé à l'époque ceci nous disait
foulard foulard islamique full
artistique vous savez pas trop nommé
avait souhaité inscrire dans le
règlement intérieur de leur
établissement l'interdiction de signes
manifestants une appartenance religieuse
c'est ce qu'on dira plus tard avec la
loi de 2004 ils en avaient demandé
l'autorisation à leur recteur puis à
leur ministre qui était alors
Jean-Pierre Chevènement l'autorisation a
été donnée en deux temps trois
mouvements
et on l'a jamais entendu parler du
problème de voile dans ce collège de
Créteil quatre ans plus tard à Creil
vous vous souvenez les plus anciens du
débat terrible qui a eu lieu en France
tout le monde était divisé dans les
familles en les télévisés
[Musique]
on est bien d'accord ça n'était plus le
même ministre et là on intergiverser et
à force d'attairement ce qui s'est
produit c'est que personne ne savait ce
qu'il fallait faire personne n'était
d'accord certain quand même savaient ce
qu'il fallait faire mais il y a eu une
grande division et les mêmes personnels
les mêmes enseignants fonctionnaires
d'État régie par les mêmes textes par
les mêmes principes et notamment par le
principe de laïcité agissait de manière
confuse et contradictoires d'un
établissement à un autre en clair
pendant 15 ans entre on a trop tardé à
réagir on a compris on a compris le sens
de votre message Maxime l'aîné on a vu
les Marianne titré cette semaine
semaines le comment dire de
l'indifférence à gagner avec cette
Marianne qui a la tête baissée qui
semble résigner est-ce que c'est votre
sentiment à vous aujourd'hui
c'est pas du tout mon sentiment dans la
mesure où on voit que les hommages à la
mémoire à Samuel à Samuel Paty pardon ce
multiplie alors je parle pas celui des
mots qui essaie de surfer d'une manière
complètement glauque pour se relever de
son échec à la présidence
et il y a d'autres hommages pour le coup
qui se qui se rejoignent enfin moi je
suis d'accord avec Madame et pour dire
qu'il faut pas instrumentaliser cette
mémoire donc il y a ces hommages qui se
multiplient donc je crois pas qu'il y
ait d'indifférence après il y a
peut-être des choses qu'on qu'on était
ratées
quand en 2021 on supprime par exemple
observateur de la laïcité que présidé
Nicolas Caden je sais pas si c'est une
bonne nouvelle
était le petit Nicolas
Nicolas Caden je crois
il travaillait et il continue de tenir
un discours qui me semble assez juste
sur ces histoires de laïcité et après
moi c'est surtout pas de la différence
et c'est surtout pas pour relativiser la
gravité de ce qui peut être fait et y
compris les menaces qui ont été faites
cette semaine sont absolument
inadmissibles voilà on la dénoncé mais
on a 313 je crois signalement sur sur
septembre il y a 12 il y a 12 millions
d'élèves si on multiplie par le nombre
de jours d'école qui a eu sur le mois de
septembre ça fait c'est un chiffre qui
est en très forte
ce sont des signalements d'événements
donc à la fois à chaque fois c'est
plusieurs élèves sinon ça ne remonte pas
à la hiérarchie d'accord c'est vous qui
avez raison et même le ministre a
concédé qui avait une vraie progression
une vraie aggravation même les autres
services ministériels
ça m'étonne pas mais donc encore une
fois peut-être aussi que peut-être qu'on
va se mettre d'accord là-dessus
peut-être qu'il y a plus de signalements
qui sont faits précisément depuis
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty parce que
forcément le vu l'horreur de de
l'événement et ben dès qu'il se passe
quelque chose on signale et je dis pas
que c'est je dis pas que il ne faut pas
le faire mais par exemple je dis que ça
peut permettre d'interpréter cette
statistique quoi mais par exemple
hebdomadaire pas est relativise pas
surtout la gravité de ce qui peut se
passer l'hebdomadaire Marianne revient
sur les difficultés et l'impossibilité
finalement de rebaptiser le collège de
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine du nom de
Samuel Patty alors que visiblement au
début la ville le département la
population elle-même soutenait cette
démarche peut-être alors vous allez me
tourner vers vous après coup mais est-ce
que ça aurait été est-ce que ça aurait
été à vos yeux un beau symbole de
rebaptiser ce collège du nombre de
Samuel Paty
oui étant donné ce qui s'est passé ça
aurait été un beau symbole et je pense
pas que ça aurait créé de troubles
supplémentaires parce que il faut aussi
évidemment à chaque fois mesurer
l'impact de ce qui va être fait et si ça
crée plus de problèmes que ça n'en règle
bon bah il faut peut-être réfléchir à
deux fois en location de céder à la peur
dans ce cas-là c'est il en est il en est
rien de tout cela ce qui se passe
effectivement vous avez raison ça a été
évoqué et et beaucoup ont envie
justement cette envie de et bien de de
d'inscrire cette mémoire dans la pierre
et nommer le collège Samuel Paty sauf
qu'il ne faut pas oublier qu'il y a un
traumatisme profond Samuel Paty était le
professeur d'élèves qui sont encore
aujourd'hui dans ce collège et donc les
psychologues ce sont prononcés avec le
conseil d'administration du collège donc
de d'attendre peut-être un petit peu
avant de de donner le nom de projet
n'est pas totalement abandonné
ce sont les élèves eux-mêmes donc il y a
une grande consultation qui a été faite
beaucoup de discussions et visiblement
ils ne sont pas prêts encore mais ils
attendent juste que cette cohorte si on
peut les nommer ainsi quitte le collège
pour ensuite
donner de donner ce nom le président de
l'association des amis de Samuel Paty
dit lui que c'est la peur qui prend le
dessus il ne faudrait surtout pas
installer une cible sur l'établissement
et le déplore et le déplore Fatiha
agacue vous en pensez quoi vous
aujourd'hui
ce serait symboliquement utile de
rebaptiser ce collège symboliquement
utile ce serait symboliquement fort
partout où il y a eu des initiatives
pour donner le nom de Samuel Paty à une
place à un square à de rétablissements à
chaque fois il y a une forte opposition
de certains parents les plus politisés
FCPE notamment en disant que justement
salé
faire de ces établissements là une cible
et que il fallait peut-être passer à
autre chose parce que vous savez que la
résilience la résilience est super oui
les élèves oublient pas ça autre chose
et on a l'impression que c'est peut-être
un peu ça mais non c'est un symbole fort
comme Arnaud Beltrame on a besoin de ces
figures là et ce sont des ondonne des
noms de héros on donne des noms de
personnes qui ont été
qui ont été
victimes d'actes à ces lieux là donc moi
je trouve que ça participe de cette
espèce d'autocensure de cette espèce de
gêne un peu diffuse voilà nous on a
besoin d'un discours clair la loi de
séparatisme comme la loi contre
séparatisme comme la loi de 2004 ont été
des lois d'apaisement et moi ça m'étonne
toujours et ça m'attriste profondément
que ce soit toujours comme ça
assumer les choses à dire les choses
clairement on a besoin de ces lois là
parce qu'elles nous ont protégé vous
voulez un cas précis voilà le cas qu'on
m'a soumis collège de
Paris 13e arrondissement une prof
d'histoire géo fait un cours sur la
naissance du monde musulman programme de
5e validé par la loi classique un élève
la reprise et la contestée parce qu'elle
a dit Mohamed au lieu de dire Mahomet et
après il voulait en plus qu'elle
n'utilise pas le nom qu'elle prononce
avec un accent d'autres élèves se sont
mis à contester aussi ce référent leur
image à ce moment l'élève en question me
lance un regard méchant et me qualifie
de Samuel Paty la collecte d'espagnol
vient lui dire le soir qu'en fait elle a
blessé offensé certains élèves vous
savez ce chantage à l'offense il faut
voilà puisque leur identité puisque leur
religion est présentée comme un
prolongement de leur identité si vous
osez en parler autrement que dans des
termes dithyrambiques elles peuvent vous
les offenser ces petites choses donc là
elle n'est pas soutenue par sa collègue
et elle n'est pas soutenue par sa
direction juste intervenir sur ce que
vous dites et je veux vraiment je vous
suis totalement sur le cas que vous
venez dénoncer mais il faut surtout pas
faire une généralité du prolongement de
la religion de la façon dont les élèves
ont un rapport avec la religion toujours
est-il que il est évident qu'il y a une
de l'obscurantisme aujourd'hui qui monte
dans notre pays qu'il y a des réseaux
islamistes qui s'emparent de ces jeunes
l'oeuvre de Samuel pathiquer ce qu'il a
voulu faire il a voulu finalement
éclairer les esprits cet esprit critique
qui manque tant aujourd'hui à nos élèves
à nos jeunes cette préparation à être
citoyen à la citoyenneté il y a
aujourd'hui clairement un manque dans
notre système éducatif et c'est pourquoi
il y a des choses focus
de Conflans j'étais député de trappes et
on avait justement ces faits là qui
étaient constatés avec une montée là
aussi de réflexion de remarques qui
n'existaient pas auparavant des cours
d'école qui n'étaient pas partagées
entre les filles et les garçons
plus jeune âge des huit ans devant et on
a mis en place et non mais vraiment il
faut aussi réfléchir à ce qui a été mis
en place et qui marche parce que c'est
bien beau de faire des constats mais
maintenant il faut agir surtout quand on
est en responsabilité et bien on a mis
en place des ateliers philosophiques à
ses enfants et on les a mis autour d'une
table et on leur a appris à discuter on
leur a appris le désaccord et c'est
comme ça que l'on prépare des citoyens
de long terme à l'insecte Laurent
pédagogique
nous nous connaissons
excusez-moi on vient on vient d'entendre
ce témoignage de d'une enseignante
rapportée par Fatiha gag bouchallah
comment comment aider les enseignants
confrontés à ces cas de figures ce sont
les enseignants qui sont en première
ligne face aux élèves ils ont la
pression politique sur cette la défense
de ce concept de laïcité comment les
comment les soutenir comment les aider
les accompagner alors
disait tout à l'heure aussi on a besoin
discours clair et sans doute et j'étais
un peu long en revenant 30 ans avant
mais je voulais indiquer qu'on avait
introduit l'incohérence dans notre
institution jusque là on ne parlait on
est même pas besoin de parler de laïcité
tout le monde savait ce qu'il fallait
faire à partir de 89 l'incohérence CD
il a fallu attendre 15 ans pour avoir la
loi du 15 mars 2004 sur l'interdiction
des signes détenus manifestants une
appartenance religieuse dans les écoles
collèges et lycées publiques alors ça a
calmé sa juguler ce problème à ce
moment-là d'autres sont venus et on le
voit bien c'est sans fin aujourd'hui
avec les abayas et les Kamis alors oui
on a besoin d'un discours clair on a
besoin de retrouver de la cohérence on a
besoin de retrouver de la confiance on a
besoin de retrouver de la cohésion et
on peut retrouver ça aussi à travers les
formations que nous organisons mais
comme je le disais tout à l'heure le mal
est profond ça prendra du temps alors
nous organisons des formations nous
avons un certain nombre d'outils je vous
en ai apporté ici en particulier le 20
des mécum de la laïcité à l'école qui
essaie de donner des réponses concrètes
à des situations précises je crois que
c'est un outil qui peut aider les chefs
d'établissement les enseignants les
professeurs etc bien sûr et vous parliez
tout à l'heure du meilleur hommage qu'on
peut rendre à Samuel Paty aujourd'hui je
crois que le meilleur hommage c'est de
chasser la peur de faire en sorte de de
faire rempart ou renoncement et de faire
en sorte que la peur elle est présente
elle est présente dans le corps
enseignant cette peur de t'exposer à des
menaces il y a de la peur ce qu'on a
appelé le pas de vagues on a cité
aujourd'hui encore le cas de professeur
qui ne se sentait pas de lire un texte
en hommage à Samuel Paty à leurs élèves
on me l'a dit aujourd'hui même alors si
on commence à céder à la peur c'est
justement ce que veulent les islamistes
c'est justement ça faire régner la peur
instiller la peur partout et Maxime vous
l'avez c'est quelque chose que vous avez
pu constater vous quand vous avez été
dans du corps enseignants alors vous
étiez dans des écoles primaires c'était
les problématiques sont pas les mêmes
voilà moi j'étais professeur des écoles
j'avais des élèves de 8 à 10 ans
essentiellement et j'ai jamais ressenti
ça par contre ce que j'ai ce que je n'ai
pas eu l'agence de vivre non plus c'est
précisément les formations qui sont
décrites à l'instant et l'Observatoire
non redites moi le Conseil des Sages
pardon le Conseil des sagesse de la
laïcité les ateliers philosophiques
c'est très bien alors il y en a
peut-être eu à Trappes mais bon ça reste
généraliste dans le cas des cités
éducatives donc je tiens juste à la
rappeler voilà pour l'instant ça reste
quand même l'exception et je peux vous
dire que
pour l'instant la formation des
enseignants en tout cas dans le premier
degré chaque année depuis des années
depuis l'ère bancaire c'est les
fondamentaux les fondamentaux des maths
du français des maths et du français et
maintenant
moi j'étais un style je faisais les
formations
je vous parle des professeurs des écoles
et je vous dis que puisque la question
elle est sur le premier degré moi je
l'ai pas vécu par contre c'est vrai que
moi je me suis jamais interdit par
exemple non pas de non pas de faire du
prosélytisme à l'école loin de là mais
quand on a des élèves de 8-10 ans
précisément c'est l'âge où on se pose
des questions quand on fait de
l'histoire et quand on fait des sciences
la première question des gamins à cet
âge et qui revient tous les ans c'est
c'était qui le premier homme et d'où on
vient etc donc forcément quand on
commence à répondre à ces questions là
bas on interroge y compris les croyances
familiales et moi je me suis jamais
interdit d'avoir des débats dans la
classe sur cette question voilà est-ce
que
les enseignants peuvent aujourd'hui
avoir une conception différente de la
laïcité que celle qui est portée
aujourd'hui par le pouvoir politique
est-ce que c'est autorisé d'avoir une
conception peut-être plus souple
une application des principes
différentes
je pense que dans l'ensemble on applique
la loi de 2004 après c'est vrai que
comme toutes les interprétation on le
constate aujourd'hui on va en parler à
mon il y a bien d'autres sujets sur
lequel il y a toujours une marge
d'interprétation et il faut lire un
petit peu entre les lignes et regarder
rester fidèles à l'esprit quand le texte
est pas et peut-être pas toujours assez
clair mais le fait important majeur on
va être très clair vous avez été
ministre de la Ville
je vous ai toujours reproché de ne pas
avoir soutenu votre collègue Marlène
Schiappa quand elle a voulu pénaliser
certificat de virginité
si vous êtes en Seine-Saint-Denis et
vous avez 98% d'élèves musulmans c'est
évident que vous aurez plus de
difficultés
l'élément majeur le levier le plus
important pour permettre cette cohésion
pour permettre la cohérence pour
permettre le vivre ensemble le sacré ça
vivre ensemble c'est vraiment la mixité
sociale mais aussi technique parce que
dans certains établissements des
enseignants il y a une association de
profs les émanciper qui dit que la loi
de 2004 est raciste islamophobe et j'en
ai opposé notamment au film musulmanes
quel genre de cours ils font ces profs à
votre avis le syndicat Sud qui est a été
le seul syndicat à Toulouse à refusé de
participer au rassemblement en hommage à
Samuel Paty mais qui organise des
ateliers en non mixité raciale quel
genre d'enseignement il transmettent à
ses enfants moi je suis pas très juste
vous répondez et après on va avancer
dans le débat donc c'est allez-y en
général je réponds et et je ne sais pas
d'où vous tenez ce type de
proposition excusez-moi je ne savais pas
que vous étiez présente à ce cobidité
interministériel qui était Président
de certificat de virginité qui était
dans le dans le qui est dans le le la
loi qui conforte nos principes
républicains il s'agit pas de montrer du
doigt une religion et c'est ça que j'ai
pointé c'est pas interdiction des
certificats de virginité vous savez
c'est un sujet qui est à la marche pour
beaucoup et sur lequel on est vraiment
d'autres priorités si on veut s'attaquer
à l'islamisme mais notamment l'islamisme
j'aimerais qu'on parle après s'il vous
plaît mesdames je ne le fais pas toutes
les femmes ne connaissez pas mes combats
mais je pense que sur celui-ci je n'ai
vraiment aucune leçon remarque à
recevoir de quiconque sur la sur le
sujet et j'aimerais qu'on parle à
présent de ce phénomène pour les
autorités t'inquiète ouvertement s'il
vous plaît on va parler de ce phénomène
dans les autorités s'inquiète
ouvertement le port de vêtements
religieux au collège ou au lycée qui
progressent les chiffres officiels La
Teste on va en parler dans un instant de
ces chiffres il s'agit notamment du port
de la Baya pour les femmes du camis pour
les hommes des vêtements que l'on porte
dans certains pays musulmans comment
expliquer ce phénomène y a-t-il une
forme d'instrumentalisation des élèves
de confession musulmane par des groupes
religieux on fait le point avec Maël
Morin
tenue religieuse ou pas la Baya cette
robe longue qui couvre les jambes et les
bras inquiettent l'éducation nationale
de plus en plus de jeunes filles Laporte
à l'intérieur des établissements
scolaires c'est débile parce que je
pense que une abeille comme un foulard
parce que
la seule chose qui est interdit c'est le
foulard j'ai jamais changé de tenue pour
un on m'a pas pris la tête par rapport à
ça faut-il voir une entorse au principe
de laïcité en septembre 313 signalements
ont été recensés dans des collèges et
lycées un chiffre en hausse d'un tiers
par rapport à début 2022 et la moitié
concerne le port de singe et tenues
religieux les abayas sont des marqueurs
religieux et d'ailleurs ceux qui celles
qui le font le savent très bien elles le
font en provocation donc il faut tout
simplement être pragmatique est-ce que
c'est un signe religieux oui ou non
est-ce que lorsqu'on n'est pas de
religion musulmane on porte des habayas
la réponse est non donc on ne met pas de
marqueurs de manière la même manière
qu'on met pas une grande croix quand on
est catholique à l'école c'est comme ça
c'est la loi le min du doigt le rôle
actif des réseaux sociaux dans ce
phénomène ici sur Tik Tok des jeunes
filles donnent des conseils sur comment
porter une abaya à l'école sans se faire
prendre j'ai enfin trouvé la technique
pour garder mon voile en discret au
lycée
mettre une ceinture sur la Baïa pour
aller en cours pour pas qu'ils disent
que c'est un vêtement islamiste moi
débarquant au lycée en habaya alors
qu'ils l'ont interdit un flou juridique
persiste autour de l'abeille à la loi de
2004 sur le port de cygne religieux ne
l'interdit pas directement mais elle
permet au chef d'établissement de
décider au cas par cas en fonction du
comportement de l'élève
que faut-il faire notamment face à ces
jeunes filles qui sur les réseaux
sociaux sur TikTok font une forme de
promotion de ces vêtements religieux
effectivement c'est une mode c'est une
challenge c'est du chantage c'est des
défis lancés c'est du glamour parce que
ces filles sont toujours maquillées
voilà je crois qu'il faut leur expliquer
ce que veut dire en fait le mot pudeur
on vous dit il faut décider au cas par
cas parce qu'on compte sur le
discernement des chefs d'établissement
la difficulté c'est qu'on n'a pas de
formation juridique claire et que si
dans le règlement intérieur de
l'établissement on va trop dans la
précision en disant on va interdire tel
vêtement qui fait telle taille vous
imaginez un chef d'établissement en
train de mesurer les jupes c'est
complètement idiot quelle est la
solution alors pour les pour les chefs
d'établissement qui sont à l'entrée des
collèges des lycées être un peu habile
en disant qu'une tenue correcte descente
et propice aux apprentissages est exigé
voilà donc en sport on met une tenue de
sport par rapport à la MBA il y a pas de
flou en fait parce que la jurisprudence
est constante un vêtement peut être
religieux par essence ou par destination
donc de toute façon c'est un vêtement
qu'ils veulent comme religion et qui
veulent comme marqueur identitaire et
encore une fois le problème se pose
vraiment
peut devenir un vêtement religieux mais
religieuse par destination
[Musique]
un vêtement musulman je serai un petit
peu étonné mais absolument tout vous
pouvez avoir des des t-shirts à la
gloire de Jésus dans les refusera de la
même façon même des t-shirts à la gloire
du cannabis sont les refusera aussi la
même façon l'école c'est pas le McDo
venez comme vous êtes et puis faites
comme vous voulez on est là pour
travailler on est là pour avoir une
tenue décente et plus on sera précis
dans le règlement intérieur plus on va
se lier les mains et en même temps on a
besoin de la loi qui nous protège parce
que dans le premier degré moi j'ai
beaucoup d'amis qui sont dans le premier
degré directeur ils sont confrontés à
ces problèmes là parce qu'ils sont dans
des zones ghettoïsées et ils peuvent
eux-mêmes s'abriter derrière la loi en
disant ah je peut rien faire je ne fais
qu'à piquer la loi donc la loi protège
et apaise
camis ce sont des vêtements religieux
qui doivent être bannis des
établissements scolaires selon vous
alors d'abord juste pour dire que moi
j'ai jamais dit que la loi protégée par
un voilà donc la loi de 2004 j'ai pas de
difficulté avec ça mais j'ai
l'impression quand même qu'on enfin on
va mettre le doigt dans quelque chose ou
précisément ça va être compliqué
vous l'avez dit peut-être que tous les
vêtements peuvent devenir des vêtements
religieux par destination enfin moi je
sais pas ce que veut dire par
destination précisément dans la loi de
2004 c'est quand même écrit ce qui est
interdit c'est le port de signe
religieux le droit est fait de loi et de
jurisprudence donc mais manifestants
ostensiblement sa religion vous voyez
c'est un peu plus subtil il faut que
tout le monde puisse reconnaître du
premier coup effectivement votre
appartenance religieuse donc
il passe son des vêtements qui sont
portés dans les pays de confessionnelle
majoritaire oui alors vous avez dit tout
à l'heure dans un certain nombre de pays
musulmans donc ne sont pas pourrait
porter à l'école pour beaucoup de ces
pays là donc
[Musique]
comment se positionne le Conseil des
Sages de la laïcité sur cette question
le Conseil des Sages de la laïcité à
cette exprimé en interne au ministère a
fait savoir aux différentes directions
et aux ministres lui-même au cabinet du
ministre ce qu'il en pensait dès le mois
de juin dernier le 3 juin une note était
prête et cette note a inspiré il faut le
dire celle qui a été adressée la note
circulaire qui a été adressée signée par
la secrétaire général du ministère à
l'ensemble des recteurs de du pays qui
eux-mêmes ont dû transmettre au chef
d'établissement
voilà donc c'est la note initiale à
laquelle d'ailleurs ça n'était pas
qu'une note du Conseil des Sages nous
avions collaboré avec des directions du
ministère les principales directions
pour dire qu'il fallait être et ferme
sur cette question effectivement il
s'agit non pas là d'un signe religieux
en soi d'une tenue religieuse et membre
du conseil des sages de la laïcité
Khaled benger par exemple qui est par
ailleurs président de la fondation de
l'islam de France il est bien placé pour
nous dire ça n'est pas un signe
religieux mais il peut le devenir en
effet la circulaire du 18 mai 2004 qui
faisait suite à la loi du 15 mars 2004
dit bien que certains signes peuvent
être religieux par destination et que la
loi ne se contente pas sont cités la
kippa le voile qui servir le couvrir les
cheveux qui nous reste deux minutes deux
minutes j'aimerais qu'on évoque quand
même un point important le ministre de
l'éducation nationale semble dire qu'il
y a une forme d'instrumentalisation
derrière ce mouvement de certaines
jeunes filles qui instrumentalise et
dans quel but
si vous le savez attaquerait tout de
suite et directement non il y a de toute
façon chez ces jeunes une recherche de
l'identité effectivement effectivement
c'est un geste parfois de contestation
parfois de de
fanfaron on copie on copie on provoque
et on se recherche qui on est donc là je
pense qu'il faut c'est une c'est une
réponse c'est une fin un sujet
extrêmement complexe qui appelle
finalement plusieurs types de réponses
évidemment moi je vais être beaucoup
plus direct moi je pense qu'il faut
l'interdire dans le règlement ce port
d'abaya de de de vêtements finalement
qui qui représentent quelque part la
religion par destination et je pense
vraiment qu'il fallait beaucoup plus
directement et et interdire pour éviter
justement ce phénomène de contagion mais
aussi réfléchir à la façon dont on peut
accompagner ses élèves et dont on peut
aussi lutter contre cet
instrumentalisation si elle est d'ordre
séparatiste religieuse il faut y aller
très franchement et si elle est de plus
sociétal social il faut là aussi y
répondre très vite il nous reste à peine
une minute Fatia boujala je voudrais
savoir pas peine dia il était un peu
attendu au tournant sur ces questions il
a été attaqué par une partie de la
classe politique des sa nomination
encore cette semaine elle était
qualifiée de ministre comme une otariste
par un député du rassemblement national
est-ce qu'il vous semble à la hauteur
aujourd'hui sur ces enjeux de laïcité ah
vous savez que je suis devenu principal
adjoint donc techniquement c'est mon
patron et là c'est ma titulaire
je vous le dire très sincèrement
j'aimerais qu'il tienne le même discours
en français et en France
et partout dans le monde c'est à dire
que quand il est en Anglet aux
États-Unis et qui parle en anglais ben
pour lui la laïcité ne correspond pas à
ce modèle universaliste désirable et qui
est précieux donc moi je trouve que
celui qui a été le plus
actif c'est le Ministre bancaire et faux
aussi lui rendre hommage s'il y a eu la
fin de ce pas de vague c'est aussi à lui
qu'on le doit quand t'as pas peine qui a
travaillé avec le CRAN donc une
organisation communautariste quand même
voilà moi j'ai la chance d'avoir un
recteur dans ma région qui issue de la
préfectorale et qui a eu comme priorité
voilà les missions régaliennes
Pâtis a été assassiné quand même mais ça
c'est particulièrement stupide comme moi
mais complètement subite et c'était sous
qui que c'était sous les enfants de tous
les enfants étaient tués à Toulouse
pour le 1 an de un an après l'assassinat
de Samuel Paty a invité au ministère
l'ensemble des ministres de l'Éducation
nationale tout courant confondus de ces
dernières années ils sont pratiquement
tous venus Chevènement Jospin
Châtel
Vallaud-Belkacem tous sont venus
rencontrer la famille de Samuel on va
s'arrêter là
votre chroniqueur a parlé d'offensif
tout à l'heure il y a eu une époque où
les abayas sont apparus c'était pas une
offensive c'était un test et on n'a pas
su y répondre et derrière les jeunes
filles qui portaient cet abaya dans un
lycée de Seine-Saint-Denis en 2010-2011
derrière ces jeunes filles il y avait
monsieur s'effry oui que nous avons revu
et dont nous savons le rôle funeste
qu'il a joué dans l'assassinat de Samuel
Patti on s'arrête là merci beaucoup à
tous les cas d'être venu débattre sur le
plateau delcp après la laïcité on va
parler d'une autre valeur républicaine
le mérite mise à mal au fil des ans
c'est en tout cas le point de vue le
postulat de départ de la journaliste
Sophie Coignard qui publie la tyrannie
de la médiocrité son portrait par Marco
pommier
si on vous invite Sophie Coignard c'est
pour parler du mérite c'est la promesse
de la nation française dites-vous mérite
méritocratie voilà des mots qui
reviennent souvent dans la bouche de nos
politiques
réengager la Nation toute entière dans
cette culture du travail et du Mérite la
France repose sur la méritocratie
républicaine je suis un pur produit de
la méritocratie républicaine dont
l'école est le pilier Sophie Coignard du
Mérite vous en avez diplômé de l'ESSEC
l'école supérieure des sciences
économiques et commerciales vous êtes
devenu essayiste et journaliste au Point
de vous nous retenons vos livres
d'investigation celui sur la
franc-maçonnerie en 2009 fait date
aujourd'hui vous vous attaquez à la
tyrannie de la médiocrité le déclic de
ce livre enquête c'est en 2014 lorsque
le gouvernement socialiste divise par
deux les bourses mérite pour les
bacheliers d'origine modeste mention
très bien nous avons décidé à la fois
d'élargir le nombre de bénéficiaires des
bourses et de continuer à donner un coup
de pouce à ceux qui ont fait des efforts
en effet les mentions très bien
continueront à percevoir 900 euros de
plus par an pendant trois ans le mérite
et la réussite du plus grand nombre
c'est conciliables 900 au lieu de 1800
euros Sophie poignard vous pointer du
doigt assez procureur qui discrédite le
mérite au nom de la lutte contre les
inégalités sans oublier ceux qui le
défendent pour mieux consolider leur
privilège alors quelle solution dans une
société où le mérite de l'infirmière est
moins reconnu que celui du trader
dites-vous dans une société où la
promesse scolaire ne serait plus
respectée l'école préfère valoriser les
compétences le savoir-être
plutôt que les connaissances le résultat
est implacable l'école qui devait
combler les inégalités de destin ne
cessent de les accentuer ce soir Sophie
Coignard nous avons une question pour
vous dans votre livre vous nous
expliquez pourquoi il faut sauver le
mérite mais concrètement comment peut-on
le sauver à vous la parole
[Musique]
réagir bonsoir Sophie cuana bonsoir
c'est une vache question que vous pose
Marco pommier et comment y répondre
comment sauver le mérite alors en tout
cas je vais essayer d'y répondre
indirectement et j'espère ne pas faire
trop long c'est à dire que en vérité
effectivement votre sujet est vraiment
bien fait parce que c'est en effet
en tant que chroniqueuse au point donc
quand je me suis intéressée à cette
histoire de Bourseau mérite que que la
ministre
voulait absolument supprimer
c'est-à-dire que finalement c'est parce
que le Conseil d'État ne lui a pas
permis qu'elle en a quand même laissé un
petit morceau mais là je me suis je me
suis dit il faut s'intéresser à ce sujet
c'est pas possible qu'une valeur qui
était une valeur de gauche une valeur
progressiste une valeur républicaine
soit comme ça regardez par les gens de
gauche en se pinçant le nez et dans
l'école c'est devenu une valeur de
droite pour vous c'est-à-dire ça a été
récupéré par la droite voire l'extrême
droite
Eric Zemmour on a fait un système de
campagne
je trouve que c'est absolument
terrifiant c'est une manière enfin c'est
à détournement de valeur donc comment
sauver le mérite mais très simplement en
faisant l'inverse de ce qu'a fait cette
ministre c'est-à-dire en faisant en
sorte de combler autant que possible
l'inégalité des chances alors comment
vous faites pour combler l'inégalité au
nom de la lutte contre les inégalités
donc moi je vais vous raconter
l'histoire de ces jeunes filles qui
comptait sur les 1800 euros par mois
pour faire leurs études elles ont eu
leur bac mention très bien elles
habitent en province elles venait à
Paris
1800 euros par an ça fait en gros pour
l'année universitaire en gros 200 euros
par mois ça veut dire 20 heures 20
heures de moins pour elle à faire des
petits boulots pour pouvoir chaque mois
donc
bourgeois et ben j'appelle pas combler
les inégalités pour des gens qui ont
déjà fait des efforts et le problème
c'est qu'évidemment
l'idée générale c'est de dire puisqu'on
si vous voulez on jette le bébé avec le
boudin on dit puisque il y a pas
d'égalité des chances puisqu'on y arrive
pas puisque bon voilà l'école ne tient
pas ses promesses et bien finalement il
faut considérer que le mérite et une
valeur un peu un peu suspecte et ne plus
en tenir compte et ne plus le promouvoir
parce que finalement les gens modestes
qui réussissent et bien s'il réussissent
ce sont en quelque sorte des exceptions
il faut faire les deux à la fois c'est
valoriser le mérite et lutter contre les
inégalités il faut pas choisir entre les
deux comme vous semblez dire que ça a
été fait alors le passé contre les
inégalités mais faut lutter comment
dirais-je enfin je raconte dans mon
livre un certain nombre d'histoires mais
abracadabrantesque où vous voyez que par
exemple un élève à Paris qui est très
bon en maths
s'il n'est pas dans un très mauvais
collège ne pourra plus entrer dans un
bon lycée parce que on ne privilégie pas
du tout tous les maths et le français 0
cache la misère comme toutes les études
internationales toutes les classements
montrent qu'on est de plus en plus
mauvais en maths et en français
à l'école en France et bien qu'est-ce
qu'on fait pour essayer de mettre la
poussière sous le tapis et bien on
valorise comme le disait votre sujet les
compétences le savoir-être la
citoyenneté etc et évidemment au bout du
compte on ne fait que renforcer les
inégalités de la même manière quand par
exemple un certain nombre de professeurs
des écoles me racontent comment on
allège les programmes à cause de ce que
de la massification de l'entrée de
nouvelles de nouvelles catégories de
population très modestes voir de de
langue non françaises à l'école puis au
collège mais c'est méprisé terriblement
ces gens là et beaucoup de professeurs
vous diront mais au contraire il faut
les aider les pousser les aider à être
exigeants et non pas considérer que
finalement au lieu de leur faire étudier
Balzac un peu de un peu de littérature
enfantine suffira vous soulignez quand
même dans votre livre l'absence de
mobilité sociale en France et dans les
sociétés occidentales en général mais en
France si vous citez cette étude qui dit
qu'il faut si génération à une famille
pauvre pour atteindre un niveau de vie
moyen est-ce que c'est pas ça le cœur du
problème comment est-ce qu'on peut
valoriser le mérite s'il n'y a plus de
mobilité sociale le mérite c'est
forcément l'ascenseur social quelque
part tout à fait je suis bien d'accord
avec vous un problème d'inégalité des
chances de reproduction sociale de
transmission des richesses et du savoir
qui se fait dans certaines classes
sociales et pas dans d'autres mais la
question je vais renverser la question
si je vous le permettez c'est à dire que
pour moi le mérite sinon vous le
remplacez par quoi et sincèrement les
plus grands penseurs qui appelait ce
livre La tireradie de la médiocrité
parce qu'il y a un grand professeur de
Harvard Michael sandle avait fait un
livre qui avait un peu succès qui
s'appelait la tyrannie du mede donc
c'est un peu un clin d'oeil mais ce
Michael sandle ne propose absolument
rien pour remplacer le mérite parce que
si vous
perdu tous les bouquins de tout les
penseurs possibles qui conspu le
méritent moi je veux bien mais c'est
exactement comme la démocratie c'est un
très mauvais système mais à l'exception
de tous les autres et si c'est pas le
mérite ce sera la naissance ce sera le
retour aux assignations ce sera le
retour jacoul croquant si vous êtes né
pauvre et à que la fête commence si vous
êtes né privilégié est-ce que vous
noircissez pas un peu le tableau malgré
tout parce que vous ciblez les
adversaires du mérite mais globalement
cette valeur du Mérite elle est positive
dans l'opinion dans l'opinion publique
elle est valorisée encore aujourd'hui
elle est valorisée encore une fois pas
tellement par la gauche c'est à dire que
la gauche considère majoritairement que
c'est une comment dirais-je que c'est
une sorte de de cache sexe à la
perpétuation des privilèges et que le
mérite est une enfin c'est comme
élection qui est à gauche mais par
exemple quand on entend Fabien Roussel
défend de la valeur travail il défend
aussi à travers ça je mérite bien sûr
mais vous avez
constaté quand même que Fabien Roussel
n'est pas forcément totalement
majoritaire aujourd'hui politique on
peut le dire donc c'est cela que je veux
dire et l'idée pour moi que le mérite ne
soit plus comment dire ai-je
transmis valoriser à l'école mais aussi
dans l'ensemble de la société c'est un
problème et c'est d'autant plus un
problème qu'évidemment on a des
contre-exemples horribles c'est-à-dire
quand vous voyez effectivement que le
patron d'une banque américaine gagne
3200 fois ce que gagne son caissier et
bien évidemment ça apporte du grain à
moudre aux adversaires du mérite mais ce
que j'ai dans cette enquête ce que j'ai
voulu faire c'est essayer de comprendre
comment le mérite avait été
éjecté des valeurs progressistes et
c'est notamment parce que les différents
gouvernements et là je raconte des
histoires qui moi-même un peu ahuri
c'est parce que les différents
gouvernements finalement on lâchait
l'affaire et là tout le monde en prend
pour son grade dans votre livre il y a
pas que la gauche
je
dis les points avec avec une grande
une grande fête pas porter une
responsabilité un peu trop lourde sur
notre système éducatif dans cette
dévalorisation du Mérite parce que
finalement les preuves les profs ne
peuvent pas tout ils peuvent pas lutter
contre tous les mots de la société
contre certains parents qui abandonnent
un peu leur rôle de parents contre je
sais pas moi mais la prolifération des
influenceurs sur les réseaux sociaux sur
YouTube sur TikTok contre les émissions
de téléréalité tout ça peut pas dire que
ça valorise non plus le mérite mais non
est-ce qu'on attend pas trop de nos
enseignants de plus en plus de mérite
pour son jeu de mots bien sûr est-ce
qu'on n'attend pas trop est-ce qu'on
leur demande pas trop est-ce que je
pense qu'il faut leur demander beaucoup
mais je pense qu'il faut les récompenser
beaucoup les gratifiés beaucoup et
effectivement on peut pas voyez je vous
parler des hypocrisies le président de
la République
a expliqué pendant la campagne après la
campagne que vraiment
il fallait faire porter l'effort sur
l'éducation qui est la mère de toutes
les batailles d'accord mais après on
fait quoi évidemment il faut pas il faut
pas commencer à s'intéresser au sujet du
mérite au niveau du baccalauréat il faut
commencer beaucoup plus tôt alors vous
allez me dire le sous le quinquiet
précédent il y a eu le dédoublement par
exemple des classes de CP CE1 c'est très
bien mais c'est uniquement dans les
oignons urbaines moi j'invite j'invite
les les services de l'éducation
nationale à venir voir un peu ce qui se
passe dans les dans les écoles rurales
ou j'ai pas mal enquêté pour ce livre
notamment et où vous voyez bien que ce
serait bien aussi de dédoubler
éventuellement les classes et de ne pas
déshabiller Pierre pour habiller Paul
très bien bah écoutez merci beaucoup à
vous je rappelle le titre de votre livre
Sophie Coignard la tyrannie de la
médiocrité pourquoi il faut sauver le
mérite ça c'est le sous-titre et cette
aux éditions de l'Observatoire on
accueille à présent nos affranchis pour
la dernière partie de cette émission
Mariette darrigran qui va nous éclairer
sur le mot qui a été au cœur de l'actu
cette semaine je maintiens le suspense
Brandon warrett lui a retrouvé des
archives étonnantes vous verrez sur le
comportement de nos députés dans
l'hémicycle ce sera dans quelques
instants enfin Elsa mon dingava nous
révélera les subtilités de l'article 49
alinéa 3 de la Constitution que le
gouvernement risque de devoir utiliser
sur le budget dans quelques jours on
commence par vous Mario Darry grand
bonsoir je rappelle que vous êtes
sémiologue et donc le mot vous avez
choisi cette semaine il s'est imposé
avec le mouvement de grève dans les
raffineries totales et sceaux mobile
c'est le mot grève absolument alors
c'est un mot qui est au cœur de notre
culture française il est pas que dans
l'actualité cette semaine et vous allez
voir que son histoire recèle quelques
surprises et paradoxes intéressants
alors c'est le la grève au sens de bord
de l'eau c'est ça le mouillé ou on peut
dire la grève dans les transports par
exemple ou bien la grève ce mot poétique
c'est au bord de l'eau le sable mouillé
avant les vagues et c'est le même mot
c'est le même mot nous a appris à
l'école à l'école ce n'était pas la même
chose mais en fait c'est le même mot
alors il faut revenir à la place de
Grève la place de Grève c'est l'ancien
nom de la place de l'hôtel de ville
aujourd'hui et justement elle descend en
contrebas vous avez la scène et il faut
se représenter les choses au Moyen-Âge
bah c'était une sorte de plage de Paris
Plage avant l'heure il y avait un trafic
énorme sur la scène il y avait beaucoup
de boutiques qui est des négociants des
gens qui travaillaient et du coup la
place quand on disait place de Grève
c'était cette place qui descendait
finalement un peu jusqu'à la mer alors
là on a tout un vocabulaire en français
autour de grève on a les gravats par
exemple on a le gravier puis alors mon
mot préféré c'est la Gravette la
Gravette c'est le premier nom de
l'huître et au 18e siècle dans Paris on
mangeait des huîtres comme aujourd'hui
on mange des marrons si vous voulez et
les plaisanteries qu'on faisait autour
des 18 c'était plaisanteries
gravesleuses parce que les huîtres
étaient censées être aphrodisiaque alors
on est vraiment dans notre dans notre
culture mais quel rapport avec la lourde
question des salaires un Kiwa des débats
aujourd'hui avec les entreprises mais en
fait la grève plage et la grève salaire
c'est la même chose c'est la même
association d'idées si vous voulez
puisque la place de Grève c'était
l'endroit où les gens qui cherchaient du
travail à l'aide les ouvriers quand ils
étaient des badauds si vous voulez alors
parfois il y avait des saignements bides
puisque la guillotinait voilà 18e après
la Révolution c'était le moment de la de
la guillotine sur la place de Grève mais
plus largement et surtout ensuite au 18
au 19e quand les ouvriers autour de 1848
par exemple les ouvriers venaient
chercher du travail donc c'est tout à
fait étonnant le gréviste c'était celui
qui allait sur la place de graves
c'était pas celui qui a arrêté le
travail c'est celui qui venait chercher
le travail sur cette place c'est un joli
paradoxe la jolie il y en a un dernier
pour boucler c'est que il arrivait comme
aujourd'hui que certains emplois ne
soient pas pourvu et dans ce cas là les
patrons qui venaient finalement faire
leurs annonces à la criée les petits
boulots du jour ne trouvez pas preneur
et à ce moment-là l'expression faire la
grève s'appliquer à eux c'était eux
c'était les employeurs et non les
employés qui faisaient grève exactement
en fait ils étaient en chômage technique
mais écoutez on aura appris beaucoup de
choses avec vous merci beaucoup Mariette
d'Harry grand je me tente vers vous
après en Brandon warrett bonsoir donc
cette semaine on a eu des débats encore
assez agités dans l'hémicycle sur le
projet de loi finance lors des séances
de questions au Gouvernement aussi avec
une présidence il y a le brune pivée qui
a prononcé trois rappels à l'ordre avec
inscription au procès-verbal je précise
contre Alexandre Loubet Frédéric
bocaletti tout demande du rassemblement
national et Astrid panosian pour la
majorité et on va voir avec vous Brandon
que les sanctions contre les députés
bien c'est pas nouveau Clément à chaque
législature on a le droit son lot de
mauvais élèves en 1997 c'est un petit
nouveau qui sème la zizanie dans
l'hémicycle ce député c'est l'ancien
présentateur star du journal d'Antenne 2
Noël Mamère et à peine élu le député
écologiste de la Gironde se fait déjà
remarquer
j'ai entendu monsieur Allègre se
plaindre en disant je parlais à des
étudiants j'ai vu monsieur pendreau
protesté qui se plaisait dans ce
poulailler c'est vrai que lui parler à
des poulets avant et non pas des
étudiants
monsieur et ma mère c'est une ambiance
de basse-cour c'est une ambiance de
basse-cour pour cette sortie Noël ma
mère et copera d'un simple rappel à
l'ordre mais le trublion a pris goût a
volé dans les plumes de son collègue
trois ans plus tard le coq de la
basse-cour récidive c'est un deuxième
rappel à lourde puis un troisième en
2009 mais cette fois-ci avec inscription
au procès-verbal et une amende pour
avoir fait un bras d'honneur aux député
de la majorité trois rappels alors de
Clément c'est tout simplement un record
dans l'histoire de la Cinquième
République je sais pas si ils s'en vont
mais c'est notable justement après ce
bras d'honneur il y a eu un autre geste
qui a marqué les esprits de la part d'un
autre député on reste dans la même
famille politique avec le socialiste
henri-emmanuel i en 2011 l'ancien
président de l'Assemblée nationale
déclenche une vague d'indignation alors
que le Premier ministre François Fillon
prend la parole s'exprime sur la fameuse
réforme de la fiscalité Henri emmanuely
bouille sur son siège et des rap
c'est vrai Monsieur Emmanuel il y a un
pays qui fait mieux que nous c'est
l'Allemagne et pourquoi l'Allemagne fait
mieux que nous parce que l'Allemagne
sous le gouvernement de Monsieur
Schroeder a fait plutôt les réformes que
nous sommes en train de faire en ce
moment la réforme du marché du travail
un doigt d'honneur au premier la caméra
était au mauvais moment mauvais
de l'Assemblée prononcera un simple
rappel à l'ordre contre Henri manuelli
alors à l'assemblé il n'y a pas que les
gestes qui sont scrutés de près qui
peuvent être sanctionnés il y a aussi
les tenues ah oui la bille ne fait pas
le député mais peut quand même vous vous
évitez quelques soucis en 2017 le député
la France insoumise de la Somme François
Ruffin va en faire les frais il est
invité à prendre la parole à la tribune
pour défendre une proposition de loi
visant à taxer les gros transferts pour
financer le sport amateur François
Ruffin ne va pas mouiller le maillot au
contraire il va le faire tomber
vous êtes la ministre des sports mais
vous ne nous avait parlé que de
compétitivité de part de marché
d'attractivité avec un raisonnement de
trader je voudrais vous en parler
autrement humainement
à l'Assemblée on ne plaisante pas du
tout avec le code vestimentaire
l'arbitre François de rugis sort le
carton jaune
au titre de l'article 72 alinéa 2 je
prononce un rappel alors à l'égard de
François Ruffin avec inscription au
procès verbal un carton jaune qui coûte
cher à François Ruffin l'obligation de
verser le quart de son indemnité mensuel
soit 1378 euros le carton rouge quant à
lui Clément est très rare à l'Assemblée
en 2011 le député communiste Maxime
grommette et le premier député de
l'histoire à avoir être tempérament sur
la sous la touche de du Palais Bourbon
et on peut quand même noter que la tenue
vestimentaire c'est assoupli en 2017
puisque la cravate le port de la cravate
n'est plus obligatoire dans l'hémicycle
merci beaucoup Brandon Noiret c'est à
vous les amandins bonsoir bonsoir alors
Elsa vous avez un scoop il paraît vous
êtes en mesure de nous révéler quand le
gouvernement va utiliser l'article 49
Alina 3 allez tout à fait mais ça je
vous le révèle à la fin de la chronique
avant ça c'est un petit peu plus
technique mais c'est tout aussi
intéressant c'est interrogé sur le texte
sur lequel le gouvernement va engager sa
responsabilité on rembobine un peu vous
le savez mercredi dernier le Conseil des
ministres a donné à Elisabeth borne et
bien le feu vert pour utiliser si besoin
ce fameux anni Linéa 3 de l'article 49
de la Constitution au moment où la
première ministre va monter à la tribune
de l'hémicycle pour l'annoncer et bien
le projet de loi soit considéré comme
adopté à part s'il y a une motion de
censure mais la version du texte c'est
un des enjeux on l'a vu le gouvernement
finalement décidé de laisser le débat se
faire dans l'hémicycle sauf qu'en étant
en majorité relative et bien et en plus
en ayant connu des partenaires en quête
d'autonomie le gouvernement a accumulé
les revers les paumes comme on dit dans
le groupe Renaissance taxation renforcée
sur les dividendes dans les entreprises
qui ont réalisé des supers profits ça
c'était un cadeau du MoDem
rétablissement de l'exit tax proposé par
les LR crédit d'impôt pour les résidents
d'EHPAD rénoversion rénovation thermique
il pourrait y en avoir encore d'autres
c'est des victoires pour les oppositions
et parfois pour les alliés de la
majorité
et les oppositions bah elles s'inquiète
elle se demande si tout ça ça va bien
est conservé dans la version finale du
texte écoutez
l'article 49-3 vous permet de nettoyer
complètement ce qui a été adopté par
l'Assemblée et de faire en sorte que
tous nos débats ne servent à rien et
donc la question que je vous pose dans
l'intérêt du débat c'est de savoir ce
que vous en retiendrez le sujet c'est
qu'il
y a cette
49,3 alors monsieur le ministre vous
demande simplement une chose est-ce que
vous allez décevoir nos compatriotes
mais elles font bien de s'inquiéter ces
oppositions puisqu'on le sait le
gouvernement il peut engager sa
responsabilité sur le texte qu'il
souhaite voté là peut être balayé d'un
revers de main par le
gouvernementiel et je choisis cet
amendement qu'il était adopté ou non
celui-ci qu'il ait été discuté ou non il
a les mains assez libres pour faire son
tri ça a déjà commencé autour du réunion
autour des ministres concernés des
quatre de la majorité alors de la veut
même des députés Renaissance ça
complique un petit peu la pédagogie
puisque c'est difficile de dire on vous
laisse discuter regardez mais à la fin
on fait le 49-3 et en plus on ne retient
rien de ce qui t'a été décidé donc quel
texte final on aura la réponse quand le
gouvernement annoncera le 49-3 alors
justement ce scoop Elsa révélé nous la
date du 49-3 on l'appelle rien comme
tout je voulais juste que vous écoutez
la chronique non on va dire
midi mardi ou mercredi je pense que oui
[Musique]
on fait des pronostics sur des sujets
aussi pointus
à tous les trois ça vous regarde c'est
donc terminé pour aujourd'hui je vous
souhaite à tous un excellent weekend et
surtout restez fidèle à LCP car vous
l'avez compris l'anneau l'actualité
parlementaire s'annonce palpitante la
semaine prochaine voilà à très bientôt
et bonne soirée
[Musique]